[Music]
while their military bombs and shells
ukraine russians came out to enjoy some
winter sun in moscow the war couldn't
seem further away here but the prospect
of sanctions is causing alarm
me and all of my friends are
very worried about war we're against war
and we are not supporting it
and
it's
we are scared of course i am waiting
this situation resolve and finish
as soon as possible of course
well it's the best way for
everybody
a number of russian banks could be
ejected from swift a global financial
messaging system used by eleven thousand
financial institutions in over two
hundred countries and territories it
lets banks from different countries
communicate with each other using
standardized secure codes allowing rapid
cross-border transactions from one
business to another being blocked will
be painful for russia's economy
yeah i think being cut off from the
system as a country it can be very
different to the economy i mean you can
imagine being cut off from the internet
right so there will not be communication
with the uh outside the world let's say
in terms of financial transactions
but do the sanctions go far enough not
for opposition politicians like vladimir
he says britain in particular could do
more the term london grad didn't come
out of nowhere and for so many years the
british financial system and the british
banking system has been used by putin's
kleptocrats to essentially launder the
money that they're stealing here from
the people of russia it is high time for
that to stop
karamosa was in moscow remembering a
friend
opposition politician and putin critic
boris nemtsov assassinated here seven
years ago today if boris nemtsov and
others like him had had their way russia
could be an open society with a
flourishing free market economy by now
instead of the increasingly oppressive
dictatorship it's become under current
kremlin management now facing the full
weight of punishing western economic
sanctions
observers here warn that sanctions could
end up hurting ordinary russians and
actually helping putin
i'm afraid that uh the
sanctions would
turn
russia
into
huge north korea
i don't think that
that the
political elite that that putin's
that collective putin
would suffer
but the private sector is also turning
on russia as bp offloads its almost 20
stake in russia's state-owned oil and
gas company rosneft
for two decades putin's rule has
benefited the rich
far more than the poor in russia the
west challenge is making sure they don't
entrench him and his constituted elite
even deeper in power
dominic waghorn sky news in moscow